>> THE NEW YORK OWNER THINKS
PEOPLE WHO ARE FEARFUL OF
OUT-OF-CONTROL CRIME IN HER
STATE ARE MERELY FALLING FOR
REPUBLICAN CONSPIRACY.
>> THESE ARE MASTER
MANIPULATORS.
THEY HAVE THIS CONSPIRACY GOING
ACROSS AMERICA THAT DEMOCRATIC
STATES ARE NOT SAFE.
IT'S REPUBLICAN STATES WHERE
THEY HAVE ALMOST NO --
THEY HAVE HIJACKED THIS ISSUE
AND WEAPONIZED IT AGAINST US.
>> --
THEIR PREVIOUS EFFECT ON
STEROIDS.
STACEY ABRAMS HOPES YOU WILL
FORGET ALL ABOUT IT >> I CANNOT
SAY NOR DO I BELIEVE IN
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
LIED AGAIN AND I'VE NEVER SAID I
BELIEVE IN DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> WHAT --
>> WHAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HIS TRANSFORMATION.
OUR BROADER CONVERSATION HAS TO
BE HOW DO WE TRANSFORM WHAT WE
SEE AS PUBLIC SAFETY SO THE
ENTIRE PUBLIC CAN BE SAFE?
>> THEY HAVE TRIED TO CREATE
THIS NEW "IT'S A REPUBLICAN
VERSUS DEMOCRATIC STATES," WHERE
ITS LIBERAL CITY IS DRIVING UP
CRIMES.
YOU CAN SAY REPUBLICAN STATES
HAVE MORE MURDER, BUT --
>> OR ATLANTA, ONE OF THOSE
THINGS.
A HIGHER CRIME RATE.
>> JESSICA, STEW IN IT!
>> I KNOW ABOUT REPUBLICAN
MAYORS.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT THEM IN A
MINUTE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE WILL SEE A FEW LATER.
>> THE LEFT HAS BEEN BLINDED BY
THEIR ZEALOTRY FOR THIS SOCIAL
JUSTICE TAKING THE SIDE OF
CRIMINALS FOR TWO YEARS NOW THAT
THEY HAVE MISSED THE FACT THAT
THERE IS THIS REALITY OF PEOPLE
BEING VICTIMS OF CRIMES IN THE
PLACES THEY CLAIM TO BE
REPRESENTING, SO MINORITIES,
WOMEN.
FOR THEM TO SIT THERE AND SAY
THAT IT'S JUST A STATISTICAL
PROBLEM THAT THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK IS SAYING "LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS RATHER THAN
ACKNOWLEDGING --" RATHER THAN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PERSON AND
THEIR EXPERIENCE IN
NEW YORK CITY, ONE OF THE
GREATEST IN THE WORLD
SUPPOSEDLY, THAT YOU SHOULD
BASICALLY HOPE THAT YOU DON'T
BECOME ONE OF THOSE NUMBERS IS
NOT GOING TO WORK EVER.
THEY BELIEVE IN THIS IDEOLOGY OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
BEING REFORMED, AND THAT
CRIMINALS HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK, WHICH IS
WHY THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO
CHANGE THEIR MESSAGING.
FOR PEOPLE LIKE GOVERNOR  --
IT'S TOO LATE A WEEK OUT FROM
THE ELECTION TO CHANGE THAT
AROUND AND TOO LATE FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING THE REALITY
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES BEING
DESTROYED BY A LACK OF POLICING
AND CRIMINALS BEING LET OUT OF
JAIL FOR A YEAR AND A HALF NOW.
>> KATE, A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
VOTER SUPPRESSION COMING FROM
ME.
I THINK -- DOESN'T HAVE A
CHANCE, SO IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT
I WOULDN'T BOTHER VOTING.
>> WE WILL SEE HOW IT GOES.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING SITUATION.
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION IS WORRIED THEY ARE
GOING TO START PUTTING MONEY IN
THE VERY EXPENSIVE MEDIA MARKET
HERE IN NEW YORK -- THE AMAZING
THING ABOUT WHAT HE'S BEEN ABLE
TO PICK UP IS GOING INTO THE
COMMUNITIES, A LOT OF TIMES
REPUBLICANS ARE GETTING ACCUSED
OF NOT GOING TO PEOPLE TO TALK
TO THEM, BUT I THOUGHT THIS WAS
AMAZING.
THE LATINO POETRY HONORS
ASSOCIATION OF NEW YORK IS DOING
A FUND-RAISER FOR HIM FOR
$70,000, BUT WHO CARES ABOUT THE
MONEY?
THE FACT "WE WILL BE FOR YOU
BECAUSE OUR LIVELIHOODS ARE AT
RISK HERE," THE BANGLADESHI
COMMUNITY IN THE BRONX.
"WORRIED ABOUT CRIME AND WANT
THEIR KIDS TO HAVE A GOOD
FUTURE."
THE YESHIVA COMMUNITY SAID "WE
WILL BE FOR HIM BECAUSE THE
EDUCATION OF CHOICE."
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
PEOPLE MIGHT BE CONSIDERING --
VOTING FOR NEW YORK GOVERNOR,
AND -- BUT I THINK HE IS SURGING
AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THERE IS A THEORY ON THIS
SIDE -- THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S THE QUALITY OF LIFE THAT'S
BEEN DEGRADED.
THE BROKEN WINDOWS THEORY LEADS
TO OTHER CRIMES.
THAT'S WHY -- THEY WON'T VOTE
FOR CHANGE.
>> UNTIL THE OKLAHOMA --
GUBERNATORIAL DEBATE REPUBLICAN
RESPONSES WERE THE SAME WHICH IS
"DO YOU ACTUALLY THINK THAT?
DO YOU FEEL THAT WAY?"
SO MUCH ABOUT WHAT GOES ON WITH
CRIME IS WHERE DO YOU FEEL SAFE
AND UNSAFE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, AND THAT IS WHY THE
WEEKLY SHARE WAS INTERESTING, OF
G.O.P. ADS -- 34% THIS WEEK, THE
HIGHEST OF THE ENTIRE CYCLE.
THIS IS THE CLOSING MESSAGE FOR
THE G.O.P. FOR SURE.
WHERE DEMOCRATS MISS THE VOTE
IS -- NOT TRYING TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN GUN CRIME
AND CRIME.
WE ALL AGREE WITH THE CRIME
POLICIES.
I WANT LESS GUNS.
I SUPPORT THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
BUT I THINK WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS, ALL THIS
STUFF.
PEOPLE ARE NOT NECESSARILY
CONCERNED -- SCHOOL SHOOTINGS,
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED, BUT WALKING
DOWN SIXTH AVENUE TONIGHT, I'M
NOT NECESSARILY SOMEONE WILL
HAVE A GUN.
CONCERNED THAT THEY WILL PUSH ME
DOWN THE STAIRS IN A SUBWAY OR
GET SEXUALLY ASSAULTED,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHERE THERE IS SOMETHING LIKE A
"I CAN SEE IT" TYPE OF CRIME,
THEY TURN OFF.
I THINK THEY WILL HOLD ONTO
THIS, BUT IT IS SENDING A
MESSAGE AND AFFECTING THE DOWN
BALLOT IN THE HUDSON VALLEY,
ET CETERA.
>> JESSICA MAKES A GOOD POINT.
>> SHE DID.
>> ARE YOU SHORT-CIRCUITING?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I SEE SMOKE COMING OUT OF
YOUR BACK PANEL.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBOT.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ON THE FEEL OF
IT.
LOOK AT THE STAT -- JUST GLAZES
OVER THEIR EYES.
YOU GO TO MSNBC ON AL SHARPTON'S
SHOW AND SAY IT'S ALL A
CONSPIRACY, LIBERALS WATCH MSNBC
AND -- AL SHARPTON ON THE
WEEKENDS.
NEW YORK CITY LIBERALS WATCH
THAT SHOW.
SHE'S TELLING NEW YORK CITY
LIBERALS, WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT CRIME -- BECAUSE THEY FEEL
IT, THAT IT'S A CONSPIRACY AND
MIGHT BE WORSE IN INDIANA?
SHE LOST A LOT OF VOTES WITH
THAT COMMENT.
SHARPTON OF ALL PEOPLE HAS SAID
TO COME UP FOR THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS, THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT CRIME, AND THAT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY NEEDS MORE POLICE AND
IT APPEARED TO GO ON SHARPTON'S
SHOW AND SPIT IN HIS FACE WAS
STUPID.
SHE ALSO TALKED ABOUT LINKED --
SHE LINKS TALKING ABOUT CRIME
WITH JANUARY 6.
SHE DID A PHOTO UP WHERE SHE
RODE THE SUBWAY.
THEY CLEARED THE WHOLE SUBWAY
CAR ROUTE.
IT WAS JUST HER AND A FAKE BODY
MAN SITTING LIKE THIS WHILE THEY
GOT PHOTOGRAPHED.
DOES THAT SEEM LIKE A POLITICIAN
WHO WAS LIKE "LET'S RIDE THE
SUBWAY?"
THAT SEEMS LIKE SOMEONE SCARED
ABOUT CRIME.
>> WOULD TAKE -- SECURITY WITH
ME.